how's it going there reject nation hi
this is dan
cyber dan is with me today because
there's some nintendo trailers that came
out and i was like
there's anyone i got to do a reaction
with to just something you know what i'm
trying to say nintendo games
it's going to be dan cyber yeah great
nailed it i nailed it i didn't want to
drink two no there's no tattoos around
here so dan
streamie award-winning editor thank you
but more importantly
i mean this sincerely he has an awesome
solo youtube channel called that cyber
channel recently not long ago passed
a hundred thousand subscribers he's got
unique ass video game essays that he
does
wonderfully edited you can see why he's
a streaming award-winning editor from
there
funny informative you're also on twitch
like constantly
yeah i'm trying to be you gotcha i'm
trying
may was rough and he's also my neighbor
who i barely see
yep this is the one excuse i had to
finally hang out with him one-on-one for
the first time in a year and a half yeah
this is how it works this is how it
works when you're youtubing
you're youtubers and you're so busy all
the time i know you're 60 seconds away
but i'll see you when a trailer comes
out man
hey hang out i have so much to do so
we'll kick it off today with uh the
sequel to breath of the wild a game that
i know dan is
very much hyped about ain't that right
mr cybert
yes way to go way to yes and and i got a
little link here
to show my support
[Music]
that's a good click
and ted thanks for watching
[Music]
i have questions many
[Music]
yeah back to the question i have so many
questions
breath of the wild so good and this just
looks like it's gonna be better
music is just as good as it always was
dan too
of course of course of course nothing
less at this point
oh at the end okay that was
it thank you levitating in the sky all
right dan
daniel take it away what are your
thoughts here share with me
your wisdom since you are the expert
promote yourself through the knowledge
of breath of the wild
share your theories what leave a thought
why why how did he go through the ground
[Laughter]
so the implications of this trailer is
so
much god i gotta formulate my thoughts
let's start with the fact that you're in
the sky now so
along with this skyward sword hd is
coming out
as well first it was like oh yeah it's
the obvious choice let's
let's move everything onto the switch
and kill all the previous consoles
that's the that's the brand that's the
brand um
that's the brand dappy brand
beat the brand happy the brand tm
now it has a lot more implications
because skyward
sword takes place in a world that exists
above where zelda takes place hyrule
gotcha
so now you're on hyrule but you're also
in skyloft where skyward
sword takes place too my theory right
now
and i'm pretty sure i'm right on this
one is that
before you fight canon spoilers for
every zelda ever
you beat gannon candy is ganon's in it
so you beat gannon in breath of the wild
so it's like okay well what are you
gonna fight
that has heavy implications that you're
actually going to be fighting
the god known as demise who you fight in
skyward sword
which is essentially ganon's it's like
the prime evil
thing that like becomes ganon eventually
so to get the full experience of this
you have to play skyward sword i would
recommend if you haven't played skyward
sword
you should probably play that when it
comes out because i
think they're trying to set up like hey
maybe you should play this game before
breath of the wild 2 because we're going
to tie that in
gotcha that makes a lot of sense yeah
which also kind of implies that this is
definitely at the end of
the zelda timeline breath of the wild
did you get all that i i could get it
man
yeah i couldn't have said it better
myself
okay you just echo what's going on in
this cranium right now i'm sorry look i
i should have let you take some of that
i just kind of went
you just went for it though let me let
me say something yeah say some things
there's some cool graphics the music is
really solid
and it looks adventurous and
fantasy-filled excitement
but please is there anything else is
there anything else you want to add
because i feel like i'm taking away the
spotlight here uh
it's pretty cool but thanks i've wanted
to get a couple words in it that's okay
did you ever play breath of the wild
i've played some of breath of the wild
the only game i've beat is a link to the
past
and ocarina of time that's the only two
i've actually completed but you know how
we have like the tablet thing and that's
how you use like your powers
yes i'm aware of that okay so it looks
like they got rid of that
in favor of your arm being corrupted
which is
pretty cool like that you're not talking
to me too much you should maybe want to
talk to the audience a little more
because they might understand
oh hi i didn't see you there welcome to
the real regents
the fact that his arm's all corrupted
and that's how you use
all of the powers from the previous game
is really cool
and interesting and it's also like the
first time that anything well that's not
true you get turned into a wolf in
twilight princess but you turn into a
wolf into that princess
it's the first time that like link gets
really
mangled from his adventures like he's
taken so many
stabs and punches and bombs and all that
stuff to the face and yet he's perfectly
fine this is the first time you kind of
see like
someone who is actually damaged from the
stuff he's done which is cool
yeah but i did hear that the creators
they had to eliminate a scene
where link goes down on zelda but they
said no no to that
i forgot where i was for a second and
you know that's a reference to the
batman thing from yesterday did you oh
my god that's right i forgot about that
reference
i see what you did there i'm
contributing to the video
okay guys what do you think of the bread
of the wild no you leave
i'll take it from here this is what
happens when e3 rolls around
and if it's nintendo related i'm like
i'm doing a let's dance here
dan please interpret what i just saw say
everything that needs to be said please
dan
i just like looking at it and it's
pretty
all right guys subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
dan is very much hyped about metroid
dreads so we're going to check that one
out next excited to hear your thoughts
on it
check out that cyber channel there's a
link in the description box and pin
comment click it catch you guys soon
okay bye